Вже восени у Коломиї повноцінно запрацює завод з виробництва кабельних мереж для автомобілів
BMW та електромобілів. Він коштує компанії 16 мільйонів євро.
Зараз прискореними темпами навчають персонал. І в доволі цікавий спосіб.
Дитяче Лего допомагає дорослим навчитися швидко і за схемою збирати кабельні мережі.
Імпровізувати не потрібно. Ставитися з відповідальністю до своїх обов’язків - це головне, чого вимагає німецький роботодавець.
Помилки неприпустимі, адже йдеться про життя водіїв і пасажирів автомобілів. Тому кожен етап виробництва ретельно перевіряється і фіксується.
У разі рекламації ми завжди маємо можливість відтворити події, що відбувалося, тому що Леоні несе відповідальність за продукт 10 років
Руслан Грем прийшов працювати на "Леоні" ще в 2002 році, коли будувався перший завод в місті Стрий. За 15 років він зміг зробити кар’єру від
керівника маленької ділянки виробництва до директора  заводу.
Можливість кар’єрного росту це те, що дуже мотивує Ірину, яка за кілька місяців з практикантки виросла до інструкторки і вчить новачків.
Жінка не приховує: вимоги німецької компанії не прості, але і соціальний пакет теж за німецьким зразком. Працівників безкоштовно возять
на виробництво, обідають вони за символічну ціну, працюють по 8 годин. За понаднормову роботу доплачують.
Відношення гарне, оплата гарна, обіцяна є вся оплата, яка на нас розрахована. Все в нас є
роздруківки. Все ми бачимо наяву, що нічого не сховано, все по закону. Так як хоче кожен працівник.
Середній вік працівників - 35 років. Середня заробітна плата тут буде не менше семи тисяч
гривень. Для Коломиї і селищ навколо це непогані гроші, адже знайти роботу тут  проблематично.
Можна бути більш впевненими в завтрашньому дні. Завод не закриється через півроку, рік , два..
Керівництво заводу сподівається, що прийшли в регіон надовго. Тут помітили суттєве покращення
умов роботи інвесторів у порівняні з попередніми роками.
Повна підтримка, жодних перепон, що ми, скажімо, можемо говорити зі сторони податкової чи землеустрою, чи митниці,
чи пожежників. Немає жодних нюансів, повністю розуміння нашої присутності тут і для чого ми тутзнаходимося
До 2020 року завод значно розширить своє виробництво. Тут працюватимуть до 4000 працівників.
Щорічно Леоні сплачуватиме в бюджет майже120 млн. грн податків. Крім цього,
німці хочуть брати активну участьу житті громади Коломиї. Ще до відкриття заводу
вони зробили от цей дитячий майданчик і спонсорують різні молодіжні ініціативи.